I actually want to ask Chad a question
what is the worst possible type of move
in chess like there's a lot of bad types
of Moves Like plundering your queen
blundering mates maybe flagging in a
winning position
but what's the worst possible
thing you can do in a chess game
cheats cheating is pretty bad yeah don't
cheat
okay let's see what Chad is saying
castling into Force meat
declining on passant
getting fools mated yeah that's pretty
bad
so I'd like to make the argument
that the worst possible move in chess
oh I do see it the first time chat
from Gus and
it's when you force your opponent to
Checkmate you
so you give your opponent no chance
but to just meet you in like in one
basically do you mind analyzing games as
stream I'm gonna show uh actually a good
handful of games and it's a compilation
of people making the worst possible type
of move in chess
uh slavox wrote a script if this goes on
YouTube I'll link the GitHub
um but essentially it compiled
the highest rated games
where one side forced the other side
to Checkmate themselves so we'll see
many examples of this
and we'll start with this first game for
a lot of these openings not relevant
we're zooming through until the very end
I want to get to this position
and here
uh White's absolutely crushing
white has just a devastating attack
um the king is actually pretty safe but
in this position white play the move
white was rated 2456 I imagine when
white played this move Bishop G7 like if
you play this move you think it's
checkmates
but it's not checkmates
and the only legal move for black
is Queen takes G7 and white gets
checkmated
so technically Bishop G7 is force
Checkmate but it's forcing checkmates
for the wrong side
so this is just a taste of what's to
come
if we see the engine here
white is force mating yeah Bishop E5 is
is nice to make way for the F Pawn
and yeah F6 F7 is coming
and uh yeah white should have been
winning very soon
okay so let's see the second example I
looked at these a while ago but some of
these I I don't remember exactly
so again this is a game played between
two relatively high rated players
um we're gonna keep zooming through some
crazy end game
this is genius content oh thank you Adam
okay we're still zooming through
and I want to slow down
at this moment
this is white to move
and this one is actually one of my
favorite ones
because in this position it looks like
white is losing
and I'll go ahead and show it's pretty
simple to find the move
that forces white to get mated
yeah G5 G5 is deserving not of a double
X Clan but double question mark
almost looks like mate but
forces Queen Dick's G5
the incredible thing here
is White had a chance to draw
this is white to move
and survive
and it looks impossible because you're
down the queen you have no like
reasonable looking checks
so what to do
yeah good job to everyone saying Queen
F4
oh no my queen
we're sacrificing our last remaining
green
because after Queen days are four
it's stalemates
and it breaks my heart that might miss
us
and why not only miss this but lay
Forest plot to deliver checkmates
and it's still me because none of the
pawns can move pawns pinned King is
sandwiched on the edge of the board
now if the king moves back
then White's doing fine we just take the
queen
and then that's probably black who has
to
try and Salvage a draw
let's move on to the third example
uh yeah we're gonna skip most of the
game
and
I just titled this as no
oh this one yeah okay so it was a
situation white was like trying to get
counter play
with the Pawns
and somehow white managed to win one
pawn and then the second Pawn
I mean black should have played Rook C7
to defend it should have been winning
for back
but white won all the Pawns
and then started storming the pawns down
and the situation was reached
right here
and this is I guess another puzzle
uh it's black to move and survive
now in the game
as a common theme with all these games
in this position Black forced white to
delivery mates black played the move
Rook C5
and now White
white has two legal moves but both of
them are mate
so yeah white white has to Checkmate
black
but there was a missed draw
and the only way to to draw this for
black
is to sacrifice a rook
rotate G7 and it's a pretty simple
stalemating idea
takes and then stalemates
oh it has no time to push yeah it's very
common sometimes when you're like on the
verge of losing you have a major piece
left if you can forcibly sacrifice that
piece
sometimes it leads to stalemate miracles
okay let's move on
this next one
we're gonna see an incredible quinoa
uh let's again Zoom forward all right I
don't entirely remember what happens
here
but essentially white skin got
ripped from its shelter and kind of flew
up the board
H5 King G5
Queen H6 King H6
so the kings are
maybe
um
getting closer to each other
Queen h8
I mean black should be winning here
looks really close to winning
Queen E5 King H6
Queen takes E4
Bishop D2
Queen F5
oh was it this position
[Music]
I think it was this position what did
white play
oh no okay
so why it's uh
white doubles on the seventh rank
we keep going
check and then here
yeah Bishop takes G7 forces white to
deliver maze
that was black surviving with this move
let's check
oh so White's actually winning here
oh White's winning with with a bunch of
different moves
yeah the cleanest mating idea is to
again sacrifice a rook
hey it's FM John Curtis I appreciate the
raid if you're just joining I'm showing
a really cool collection of games which
I'll explain in just a moment
um
but here yeah whatever it takes its mate
so yeah I like this one because
like white was just losing earlier
like black was completely crushing
but somehow black couldn't find the way
to win
apparently it's made in seven after H4
and then yeah Rook G7 in some sense
forcing White
or forcing black to force white to check
May black
if that makes sense
so if you're just joining we're looking
at games where basically one side forces
the other side to Checkmate themselves
so after Bishop G7 White's only legal
moves to deliver mates
and this will be an eventual YouTube
video I think I'll probably title it the
worst possible move in chess
okay this next one's a funny one
uh we'll Zoom forward
white was having a seemingly strong
attack
okay lost The Rook but still has some
pressure
and we're gonna see white
make some progress
the players got to this position
[Music]
and white played the next move
Knight to F6
which looks devastating like it looks
like it's just checked me right like
King's attacks has nowhere to move the
Queen's also attacked
but the game's not over
black has one legal move
oh no my Rook Queen takes H1
It's gotta be the worst feeling when you
you play a move you think it's mates and
it's not mates
and then it's even worse when you
realize your opponent's only legal move
is to Checkmate you
so I think white was
probably doing fine
like if you're white here you have to
see the Rooks attacked
and any night move gets mated
so probably the thing to do is Queen H6
and then let's check with the engine
yeah Queen H6
lights crashing because Knight F6 is now
uh I'm made in one thread
okay I hope people are having fun
witnessing other people's pain
uh let's go to number six zooming
forward here
ooh wait how did this happen
some crazy position
[Music]
we'll just see the whole opening so it's
a slav
they got some structure black one Queen
side Pawns
and then White Sox the Knight
because there's ideas of Queen H6
lifts a rook
white wins H6 lifts the other Rook
oh
so here
okay I'll preface this with saying
White's just crushing in this position
like after Rook G3
uh the position looks pretty hopeless
but if you're playing Black
you might spot the fact that there's a
tactical idea to distract the queen from
defending the first rank so you can get
Rook D1
and in this position black took the Rook
and after Queen takes H6
black played Rook D1
which looks like checkmates
but it's not checkmate
and White's only legal move is Bishop
takes D1
which in turn checkmates black
so another kind of failed
attempted checkmate
I'm pretty sure black had no Escape
though
but it was a funny finish
speaking of funny finish
number seven I titled this funny finish
all right zooming through
King's Indian
I think this went pretty deep into the
end game
keep going
oh yeah this was a funny finish
okay
we should treat this as a puzzle
because black is on the verge of
queening
oh man
so white doesn't have much time
and the game white played Bishop B8
which I think was a mistake
um white should be winning with King B6
it's a crazy position because okay black
can make a queen but then Bishop B7
checkmate
and now I've worked before
white just takes Bishop here here
White's guaranteed to check needs
that didn't happen in the game
white missed the mating idea
played Bishop B8
so hugging the black king
black promoted
Knight A5
White's threatening mates
but then what happened is after Queen B1
King A6
Rook A4
white play the move which looks like
checkmates
but again it just forces plaque to
deliver mates Queen digs B7 only legal
move
and this is pretty
like the king is very useful in
defending the queen I Rook pins and
knights
and this pawn bishop configuration is
kind of irrelevant
I have three more examples next one
powerful passive Bishops
ah this one
all right we're gonna Zoom through
so here
somehow Black's King just started
walking up the board
and what happened
was B4 check
King A4
thank you salmon shark Checkmate my
money
I'll be happy to
thanks for getting merch and things for
the money so King A4 it looks like box
in good control
like the Rooks are well placed the
king's active looks like this queen Side
Pawn is falling Bishop's attacked
but in this position white undevelops
the bishop
Bishop C1
and then black plays a move which looks
like maiden two
like if you just focus on the Rooks and
the bishop you can calculate Rook takes
Rook Bishop takes in rookie one
checkmate
the only problem is when
black takes on D1
white undevelops the other Bishop
and it's checkmates
the passive Bishops are too powerful and
the pawn formation is so clutch like all
these squares are controlled
Bishops cover everything else
so this was pretty nasty because it
looked like white was in trouble and
then
all of a sudden white just had to like
had to check my black
and it's such a weird mating pattern too
like just two Bishops on the back rink
this is probably one of the best ones
all right let's look at the the next two
uh again zooming for it so white is ooh
it's actually confusing because there's
this
interesting alignment along the long
diagonal
the white should be in very good control
get ready for it
yeah why is this up so much material
but as black you don't resign
and get ready for it
so in this position I'm pretty sure
white played a move
thinking it's Checkmate or maybe
thinking that it's simplifying I mean
how much material is white up a queen
and a rook the thing to understand black
wants to Checkmate by moving The Rook
along the G file
so white play at the move Queen G5
forcing The Rook to take and it's
checkmates
like any move to attack the bishop
should be winning for whites
a Queenie for Queen D5
a queen G5 just so the worst thing to do
I'd probably play Queen D3 I guess uh
yeah Queen F6 looks playable but this is
also very bad because Rook G6 checkmates
so I hope some of these examples
make people feel better about their own
blunders like when you blunder in a
chess game
it could be a lot worse
like there's there's varying levels of
plundering all right let's look at this
last one
so apparently there is a nice Maiden two
Zoom forward
have some Rook ending
ah this one
yeah this is a cool one
it was a crazy position White's on the
verge of queening
and I'll treat this one as a puzzle this
is black to move Checkmate in two moves
and not only will we deliver Maiden two
but we're gonna Force whites
to force us playing Black to Checkmate
White
if that makes any sense
oh it's so funny I see Rook C1 Rook C8
and Rook F1 uh I know some people uh
maybe it's hard to orient yourself
notation wise
but good job to those saying
Rook C8 yeah Rook F1 is here The Rook is
on C1
thyroxia we sacrifice The Rook
and then in the game
white took back making a queen
I guess white could have under promoted
under promoting is actually a better
move because then you don't force black
to deliver the mate
but white promoted to Queen
and then checkmates
those are cool amazing idea so anyway I
hope people enjoy these
uh this will probably go on YouTube let
me know if you like content like this
and big things to sloth Fox
I'll link the GitHub in the video
description and maybe maybe we can scour
leechas for more examples of
such a pattern